a popular talking point from the I guess
we could call it the red pill right I
don't really know what to call it but
anyway you know the group I'm talking
about this talking point is criticizing
those who say I'm offended right anytime
somebody says I'm offended they respond
and say I'm offended isn't an argument
you need to engage with the facts and
you need to make a real argument I agree
with them generally I agree that saying
I am offended or that's an inappropriate
question is not an argument one way or
the other and yet the same red pill
right is cheerleading Ivanka Trump for
saying that asking her about the dozens
of sexual assault allegations against
her dad is an inappropriate question
when an NB c-- news reporter asked her
about it let's check out the clip and
then there's a lot to say about it and
on accusations of sexual misconduct
against President Trump allegations he's
repeatedly denied do you believe your
father's accusers I think it's a pretty
inappropriate question to ask a daughter
if she believes the accusers of her
father when he is affirmative Lee stated
that there is no truth to it I don't
think that's a question you would ask
many other daughters I believe my father
I know my father so I I think I have
that right as a daughter to believe my
father inappropriate question it's
basically like I'm offended by your
question right if the question is a
misplaced question because Ivanka would
have no way of knowing the truth for
example or because that's a personal
issue that she feels she can't speak to
or she's being interviewed in her
capacity as an adviser not as a daughter
so she can't speak to it or if she just
wants to say I know my dad and he would
never do these things so the question is
irrelevant then say that right don't say
it's an inappropriate question now I
would disagree right I'd say listen the
idea that she's an adviser and not the
daughter or she's the daughter and not
advisors or whatever she's
basically both she is the daughter she
also has this position because they've
been able to circumvent nepotism laws
where she is an advisor to the president
she's representing the President on
women's issues around the world she
claims to defend the rights of women so
I would actually argue that it's a very
relevant question for Ivanka Trump but
any of those answers would be better
than the question is inappropriate she
went to the world assembly for women in
Japan last year and she said all too
often our workplace culture fails to
treat women with appropriate respect
this takes many forms including
harassment which can never be tolerated
she's written that she's experienced
sexual harassment many times on the work
sites of her own father so she is a very
good person to be asking this question
to now as far as her arguing which she
didn't she's basically saying based on
my knowledge of my dad I don't believe
the accusations putting aside the really
weird and creepy things that Donald
Trump has said and done about of a to
and about Ivanka Trump herself in the
past it's really difficult for me to
believe that Ivanka Trump has no
knowledge of any of these accusations
and all of the things that he has done
in the past including the affairs
including all of the other stuff so what
do you do when the facts are ones you
don't want to deal with you say the
questions offensive or it's an
inappropriate question and you sort of
put the interviewer on the defensive
right and she presents herself as
advocating for women by virtue of being
part of trumps administration she
presents herself as a representative of
the administration around the world and
this is a very appropriate question to
ask her I feel like if this answer came
from Tiffani Trump it would be it would
be acceptable because they'd be if eni's
Trump didn't sign up for this she's the
daughter of the president but she's not
serving in any public capacity not an
official role I don't desert
where's Ivanka Trump decided that she
wants to play a role in women's issues
and be a voice for the White House and
both Ivanka and Don Jr and I don't know
if Eric Trump has done this but Don jr.
and Ivanka definitely do it when there's
a question to them in their capacity
as advisors that is uncomfortable they
say I'm just the kid I'm the daughter I
mean you can't ask me stuff like that
and then all of a sudden when people
question what why is the daughter of
Trump an advisor at the White House they
say I am a well respected woman of
business and education and culture and I
am fully qualified to be here
representing the United States it's this
selective switching between being staff
and being kids based on what's
convenient that's disgusting and there
are actually real questions when it
comes to Ivanka about appropriateness
right when we rightly question why
Trump's unelected daughter is sitting in
for her dad at the g8 summit or who
knows what it was
she is a well-qualified adviser to the
President and handles matters of
importance and then all of a sudden when
we say what's your position on the
serial sexual assault allegations
against this man it given that you work
on women's issues oh I'm just a kid I
don't know that's not an appropriate
question I wouldn't be surprised if
after the Trump presidency of the United
States decides to ramp up its
anti-nepotism law tighten him up because
there are just so many conflicts of
interest here yeah and they've been able
to get around them I mean Ivanka Trump
Jared Kushner there's financial
conflicts involving all sorts of other
people in trumps cabinet it's been
really the opposite of draining the
swamp and really the the truly
inappropriate thing is what Donald Trump
is accused of doing right truly vile
horrible depraved things up to and
including the alleged rape of a 13 year
old girl that's the really inappropriate
part along with Ivanka having a job with
the White House the questions not
inappropriate at all send me your
thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman show
is on Twitter at David Pakman show back
after this today's episode of the David
Pakman show is made possible in part by
brilliant you watch the David Pakman
show or listen to the David Pakman show
so clearly you're interested in politics
and in following what's going on in the
world and the economy the environment
but what's crucial to understand is that
almost everything we talk about on this
show is sort of on the foundation of
math science and philosophy and keeping
up with the news is one thing but you're
never really fully equipped to
understand political issues
have debates with people until you've
actually developed a more complete
understanding of how the world works and
how these issues work at the most
fundamental level and brilliant is one
of the most effective and enjoyable ways
to do that that I've ever come across
you can learn hands-on about statistics
crime climate science energy it's a long
list and you can get started right now
by signing up for free at brilliant org
slash David Pakman first two hundred
people who visit brilliant org slash
David Pakman will also get 20% off an
annual premium and membership check it
out sign up for free today at brilliant
org slash David Pakman